would it be fair to say when you're
evaluating individual companies you're
very bottoms-up but just hearing you
talk through a lot of this in past
conversations we've had I think that you
guys take this macro view of kind of
where where are we today
macro wise where are we going and then
you go look at the companies in those
areas in which you guys believe will
have upside in the future and a lot of
times it's even places where maybe
they're not popular today but they end
up being and then when you find those
companies you start bottoms up
is that a fair way to view kind of the
process you guys go through about say on
a week to week basis even on a month to
month or a year to year we might have
theses that continue to get form top
down by our Bottoms Up work and vice
versa right where our assumptions like I
think the way we think about is the the
when we get into the room and we're
assessing any company anything bottoms
up is that we just don't know anything
we just check everything out the door
and so we just don't know so what are
the assumptions we may have made they're
wrong what are these new assumptions we
should start making now based on this
data and how does that help inform us
for our long-term capital to point
remember we're venture investors so our
timeline is 5 10 15 20 years in some
cases
as an angel investor right I have a I
have an investment from 2005 that's
still not liquid right it's still there
and I'm still hanging on and you know
and then we start thinking about going
from 10 to 50 to 100 and 200 investments
the your your thesis has to be different
you have to start thinking about your
portfolio your liquidity means for
yourself in your LPS but also what you
need to do in order to make better
decisions in the macro and micro
environment the reason macro is
important is you have to understand the
bottoms of demand signals you see are
they going to continue to see tail winds
are they gonna hit headwinds are they in
a regulatory environment or not and and
I think you know what you've seen
unfortunately in again housing education
in health care sort of being the the
main ones that focus on the reason why
they've had a harder time is that
they're they're more akin to political
and regulatory behavior where you have
institutions that are set to make sure
those things
stay status quo it's hard to innovate
and so even if you see a company that's
bottoms up they might have a small
initiatives working thing gets slapped
down by the regulatory side of the house
and and sometimes that may or may not
work right like in the case of uber they
had a lot of turmoil sort of left they
were able to make it through because
what was happening is that we were
moving away from a world of being
regulated to a world of being
unregulated to make it more beneficial
to the consumer make it more beneficial
in my opinion to the folks that were
being employed to make money through
that to that remnant inventory the same
with air B&B et cetera so you kind of
have to look at that and say well what
is what are going to be those types of
change that will happen that are
effective for education health care and
housing and the question you ask is in
this environment is that helping to
accelerate some of those industries to
deregulate and get more innovation and
to be able to help build in that
direction or are they gonna stay status
quo and that's where we spend a lot of
our time thinking through which is you
have to understand that part of the
macro and gather data on that side as
well and and that's the hard part like
that's the art on top of the science
which is science is not gonna tell us
what's gonna happen we're we can only
know what's happening on the ground and
we can only know again bottoms up make
you know actual trends and demand
signals we don't know how long that's
gonna last depending on what type of
environment what type of investment
we're ranking and so that's why we do
focus a little bit of our time on
lobbying we focus a little bit of our
time building those relationships with
you know a central government and no
mchale OTT of people don't like to say
it but you know I think the biggest
threat to the United States is not
understanding what's happening in Europe
what's happening in Africa what's
happening in India what's happening in
China and in China more specifically now
I'm not I'm not like I think longer term
we have a better model of incentive
alignment here in the United States like
we have last 400 years however China
understands their incentive model
they're copying us they're getting into
that direction and even though they are
centralized they've been figuring out
ways to deregulate pieces of their
economy to be
be able to innovate the same way which
we do here in the United States but at
the same time they do have a top-down
macro perspective on what they need to
focus on and we've lost a lot of that in
my opinion here in the United States
post-world War two up until maybe to the
early to late 70s and 80s you know I
went to a China what they call the de
china fin tech conference and who here's
who put it up
you had the state government of China
the People's Bank in the name of China
you had the top ten universities and
stand this up and there was only one
outside speaker and one outside
participant and that was me and I went
there with thinking I'm curious to see
what was gonna happen and I and I and I
did a keynote speech there on behalf of
not just us but even our company card on
what's happening in the financial
industry and on there you know before I
had started they had a couple days of
all the companies that were pitching you
had some of the your the heads of
government you know the heads of states
their you know the heads of universities
their get innovation cycles you have
startup companies they're like the top
ten and then you have folks like $0.10
all about all these guys they're talking
about what's gonna happen you basically
add the smartest people in the room
regardless of market cap talking about
what is important and guess what they
were talking about they were talking
about how much we need to pay attention
to crypto what reserve currencies look
like in the future where they need to
innovate where they need to subsidize
where the government needs to spend more
time helping companies get off the
ground and where in the world should
they be paying attention and you know
luckily for us you know I you know we've
been in the lead for a while but we have
to be kind of vigilant is that they
basically said the only country we need
to pay attention to the only Innovation
Centers we need to pay attention to
nowhere else in the world we need to pay
attention to is the United States and
Silicon Valley specifically